that's the break he needs to bring you
Sky News understands that Boris Johnson
has written to the chancellor to
formally resign as a member of
parliament he made the announcement at
the end of last week but now that formal
letter has gone in let's bring in our
chief political correspondent uh John
Craig John
no going back now he's done it he's
officially sent in the letter to the
chancellor of the ex jacket why has he
done that oh it's a quaint older
tradition if an MP resigns from the
House of Commons midterm mid Parliament
they have to apply for what is called an
office of office of profits under the
crown which means a paid office which
means they are disqualified for becoming
an MP because strictly speaking the only
people who can get rid of a an MP are
there constituents by voting them out
there are two of these offices of profit
under the crown one is called the manner
of northstead which apparently is a plot
of land somewhere up near Scarborough in
North Yorkshire and then the other one
is the Chilton hundreds obviously in the
chiltons are not far from Checkers no
doubt so so far we know that Nigel Adams
who is the MP for uh or was the MP for
Selby and Einstein in North Yorkshire uh
twenty thousand or so majority there he
is officially quit uh Mr Johnson now
Uxbridge and South ruislip majority
around about seven thousand he has
formally applied to quit we await news
of Nadine dorries uh mid bedfordshire
majority nearly 25
000 there
um we're not really expecting any more
at the weekend there was all sorts of
heady talk of half a dozen or so of
these uh Johnson allies quitting well
there's still only there are only three
we're not really expecting any more we
await formal confirmation from the
treasury what happens is is that the
treasury always puts out a notice saying
they've been appointed to these office
officers of crop profits under the crown
we'll probably get those later this
afternoon then of course uh presumably
once Nadine Doris has gone the Tory High
command the chief whip the Prime
Minister party chairman all those people
have got to decide when they want to
hold those by Alex actions now
everything suggests that Rishi sunak and
the party's uh High command will want to
get them out of the way as soon as
possible so they will hope to have those
three by-elections in uh sometime during
July and they will hope that this
Dreadful feud between Mr Johnson and Mr
sunac which has really erupted today uh
will come to some sort of truce not sure
about that mind you I mean just to recap
what we've had today after in a week
after a weekend when they were saying to
the Prime Minister need to get a
backbone when he seemed to get one this
morning when he said that uh explainer
Boris Johnson asked me something to to
do something I didn't think was right in
other words Noble the vetting committee
get them to change their mind about my
uh my recommendations for peerages I
said no Mr Mr tunak said if people don't
like that tough and then Mr Johnson has
hit back this afternoon by saying Mr
sunac is talking rubbish actually got
some on the record words from Mr Johnson
himself rather than some of his friends
talking anonymously on his behalf so the
latest twist it's official Adams and
Johnson have applied to go we await
confirmation that it's all over for them
and then the government can think about
when they're going to move the Writ for
the by-elections we await news of Nadine
Doris as well but the whole process is
moving on and we're moving towards those
by-elections the government will no
doubt want to hold them in July